I promise you this is exactly how every
trucker shoot goes it's completely
unorganized and Eugene is drinking
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so this is how this going to work one at
a time we're all going to do our impress
into each other and then you guys gonna
tell us how we did and then we'll see
who the winner is at the end of all this
sack Kornfeld zach is like well I woke
up hey I got a man not that Joey never
was shooting try guys videos his default
is to go into like a spring toy you're
learning about this so the one thing I
know about zach is that besides being
adorable he's perpetually single and
I've been in many bars with him so I'm
gonna do Zack talking to girls at bar
hey I'm Zack I'm Zack you like you like
Jeff Goldblum Jeff Goldblum is like the
best Jeff Goldblum is the best I've
never been so attracted to you gene that
was really like yeah I'm feeling that so
there is this the small like this is
very quiet loving Ned my favorite colors
red because it rhymes with Ned so I was
making dumplings with my wife the only
impression ever do it Ned it's just yeah
good song I forgot the noises baby take
night every Wednesday
and the go which means we're missing it
ah this show what I like about Keith is
when he takes a photo he likes his own
name a lot so rather than saying cheese
he just says Keith is like the humanoids
Muppet he just somehow can like to speak
about nothing for forever we all like
birds who doesn't like birth I love
birth so but he had two Stan's that I
can't do bits like there it is it's like
you're skiing when he gets undressed he
takes his shirt off over his head and
then goes I can see how much you guys
get undressed that you know this is
gonna be tough because I have to tell
you this is how this man actually walks
around the office you can tell he comes
from Texas when he walks he always like
a quarter turn he lets you look at him
first huge evil like he'll he's always
so perfect for when it comes it's like
hey so uh we just shoot yeah we're all
over the USA book okay yeah you're out
there and then just
[Music]
[Laughter]
basically yes that was I didn't wanna I
don't wanna keep you here all day so
ladies how do they do
oh I think Zach one we talked about it
yeah Zach one that one let's really clap
for the fact people that Eugene didn't
win
[Applause]
[Music]